selon vous qui à qui appartiennent ces
vergetures
ancienne Miss France
effectivement et elle a posté cette
photo elle s'est fait massacrée sur les
réseaux parce qu'on a dit c'est ça la
plus belle femme du monde elle a ici là
on voit mal à se pixelisé mais ici elle
a des petites bergetures
la plus belle femme du monde c'est pas
elle désolé il y en a beaucoup plus
jolie sans vergetures elle va vieillir
c'est vraiment bien et encore elle a du
maquillage elle a répondu en 2023 il y a
encore des gens choqué par des
vergetures j'ai toujours eu ces
vergetures ça n'a jamais péché les gens
de me trouver belle je voulais juste
nous dire parce que je l'avais un petit
peu j'avais un peu dit qu'il était un
peu plus sur TF1 tout ça et moi
honnêtement j'aime pas quand ton petit
les femmes donc contrairement à ce qu'on
pense c'est pas que je ne les aime pas
je n'aime pas quand on les utilise mal
je trouve que ce qu'on a fait là c'est
totalement dégueulasse en plus souvent
c'est héréditaire tu peux les avoir à 18
ans je ne comprendrais jamais la
méchanceté la violence des gens sur les
réseaux sociaux faites vous soigner il y
a du vinaigre dans votre sang secouez
vous vous êtes une vinaigrette
j'ai eu son compagnon au téléphone
je suis désolé Catherine dans deux
minutes vraiment dans 2 minutes tu
intervient j'ai eu son compagnon au
téléphone cette semaine s'appelle Diego
El Glaoui parce qu'elle fait partie de
son
compagnon il s'appelle Diego
ça veut dire
des origines voilà c'est lui s'imaginer
la sécu monsieur eldia oui oui
pas drôle c'est pas drôle
oh là là Monsieur premier degrés
c'est lui qui gère c'est lui qui gère
c'est son agence qui gère l'image de
d'iris depuis quelques années et c'est
le genre de voilà de de contenu
sponsorisé qui font partie d'une
stratégie il a il a il a il a multiplié
son chiffre d'affaires par 10 justement
parce qu'il se voilà il se prend pas la
tête sur voilà c'est une façon d'être
populaire et en même temps d'être belle
parce que c'est une très belle femme
donc elle est très très bien drivée
coacher assume tout ce qu'elle fait et
je pense que tous les commentaires qui
en plus tu m'as cassé une vanne pour
dire un truc un peu
merci
Édouard ça me fait tellement plaisir non
mais elle est d'abord elle est très
sympathique iris mais le problème sur
les réseaux sociaux je trouve que en
général les ce sont les femmes qui se
bastonnent entre elles mais souvent
souvent c'est des réflexions de meufs
envers des nanas
et je trouve que c'est triste justement
qui est pas cette espèce de sororité à
un moment donné faut un tout petit peu
serrer les coudes entre nous parce qu'on
a déjà un monde dans lequel on vit qu'un
petit peu compliqué et je trouve que
entre femmes le jour où ça cessera ce
genre de de commentaires mais vraiment
fais-le le monde ira beaucoup mieux
excusez-moi vous écrivez votre texte
ensemble
[Rires]
mais tu es marrant je suis dans la merde